có cảm nhận thấy là cái công tác bầu cử
đã được sống bị rất chú đau từ rất sớm.
Tìm tất cả tự vật tà mọi được kiện thoần lấy nhất,
cho cử chỉ một kính hoàn cảnh nào cũng đều được tẻ hiện.
Cái ý kiến của mình là phíau của mình.
Và đây là cái quyền thật hiện, cái quyền xanh chủ, chức tiếp,
hứa trọng được cái kinh gây mà mình tính giảm.
Tìm tất cả tự vật tự vật tự vật tự,
tự vật tự vật tự vật tự.
Tự vật tự vật tự, tự vật tự vật tự.
Cái cuộc bầu cử, của họ đã muốn nhớ tất cả tự vật lần này.
Là sau khi đã được quán chết những cái...
vẫn để kêu bàn nhất của được loi,
chủ trường chi sẽ cỚc đạm nhà nước và quỡ trở.
Các tự vật tự vật tự, những dân đá rất đông tự vật.
có người hỗ lấn của đất nước.
Đây, đây, thấy hiện được tựa, tựa, tựa, tựa, tựa lắm chụ của mình,
cách chực tiếp để lợi chọn những người có được đồ quy tín, tín nhận.
Vậy và cách công việc chụng của đất nước của người là cuộc cách được.
Còn đưa đất nước chúng ta hát chạy.
Và bảo ra mắm,
Đặc biệt chủ quyền, con trận, lính thò, bảo vệ tổ quốc tụi tên, mọi người bịnh vực.
Đặc biệt chủ tên, phát triển, mọi két, bịnh vực, on lịch, nhàng, đồng thời,
là nân theo đời xong ngoại mặt quý.
Như dân.